I don't think olaf should get to rearrange
This is gonna be a cinch two sisters one mind, okay?
Here we go. You got this Elsa
Anytime just do something with your body. Um, nothing err
Tree people Trippel. Is that a word? That's not a word Oh
Shovel boy. Teeth Oh
Pillow forts, so in the library playing charades. Yeah, and this you
Olaf has just won because
He can rearrange right and so Christophe got him bang bang bang. It's boys against girls
You're not a huge fan of that, but you have complete faith in you guys and you and Elsa
Okay, the key to this and I say have fun
Play with whatever you come up with is Elsa is so bad at charades. It's almost impossible to come up with writing
So I said just just play. Okay. I see what you've got
Okay
Lion briefly bear monster. I'm very angry bear
I'm a demon on slightest mistake of your life. We didn't even kiss you
We all kind of got it
Did we hurt your feelings? I'm so sorry. If we did, you know, very few people are actually good at family games
That's just a fact
We made a promise not to shut each other out
Just tell me what's going on
You're not going alone well, you're not going alone
Excuse me, I climbed the North Mountain survived a frozen heart and saved you from my ex-boyfriend and I did it all without powers
So, you know, I'm coming
Okay, so it's just you confronting her a little bit and also it's just trying to hang on to her - no
I think you're starting to sense if she's
Pulling away a little bit. So it's like come back to me. Also, come back. Okay
Christophe can I borrow your wagon and Sven? Mm-hmm. I'm not very comfortable with the idea of that. You are not going alone
Oh, no. No, I have my powers to protect me. You don't excuse me
I climbed to the North Mountain survived a frozen heart and saved you from my ex-boyfriend and I did it all without powers
So, you know, I'm coming me too. I'll Drive. Oh
I will look after your people. Please. Make sure they stay out of the kingdom until we return of course
Let's let them know honour
I'm worried for her. We have always feared Elsa's powers were too much for this world
Now we must pray they are enough. I
Won't let anything happen to her the next right thing is for me to go to the enchanted forest and find that voice
Kristoff can I borrow your wagon and Sven I woke the magical spirits of the enchanted forest
because of the voice
Because of the voice I know it sounds crazy, but I believe whoever is calling me is good
I know we did this together and we'll continue to do this together
Anna I need to ask you a question
Do you want to build a snowman
So that's what this is really about. You're finally confessing it. Although not an ominous voice. It feels something about it feels, right?
Yeah
It feel it's speaking to your magic in this way that says it's good
and it's not something anyone else can understand but you appeal to Anna and
She will she will understand. She's your sister. So that's all these aren't. Okay. Cool. Okay Olaf you're up
Okay, I'm ready. I'm ready
go unicorn ice cream castle oaken teapot Mouse Oh
Elsa okay Olaf you're up. Okay
So much easier now that I can read. Mmm lightning round boys against girls
I'm ready. I'm ready go
Unicorn ice-cream castle oaken teapot Mouse Oh Elsa, I
Don't think Olaf should get to rearrange did you know sleeping quietly on long journeys prevents insanity?
Did you know sleeping quietly on long journeys prevents insanity
Olaf
Did you know sleeping quietly on long journeys prevents insanity?
Sven keep us steady. Will you honor mhmmm honor?
Remember our first trip like this when I said you'd have to be crazy to want to marry a man you just met
No, I did but you were not crazy clearly, huh? Just
naive not naive just
New to love like I was and when you're new you're bound to get it wrong
What no no, no. No. I'm not saying you're wrong or crazy. I'm saying that it's
Nothing's gonna happen to arond Oh Anna it's gonna be fine. Come here
You know under different circumstances this would be a pretty romantic place don't you think
Just in case we don't make it out of here no, no no, I mean we will make it out of here well
Technically the odds are kind of complicated but my point is in case we die. No no, no
No, we will die at some point, but not at any recent time will we die no, but wait in the future we will
Don't patronize me
Reindeers are better than people Sven. Why is love so hard?
You feel what you feel and those feelings are real
Come on Kristoff. Let down your guard
bird
The gang's doing charades. Okay, Jonathan, so you are on a team with Olaf. Okay, and
Boys against girls and Olaf can rearrange very easily and do these shapes that hardly anyone else can do
You get the stuff right away
Instantly he does it. So you're you're right on it with all of these these lines hairs. So yeah, and this one here
it's because
Olaf as almost acting out and slicing the air like she's got a sword guesses Hans
Which she's like it's close, right and you of course loving this. Yes. This is the greatest greatest mistake of your life. Yeah
You got it Oh, I'm just living the dream honor. Oh, I'm just living the dream honor. Oh
how I wish this could last forever and yet change mocks us with her beauty and
Yet change mocks us with her beauty
Forgive me maturity is making me poetic
Tell me you're older in the song knowing do you ever worry about the notion that nothing is permanent
You're living the dream you're lying in the Sun and just as you're doing that. It's starting to cool down and then a
leaf of fall falls and
Symbolizing change and this is also symbolizing your maturity, which is going to okay be a big part of this film
It's all on you. So this is this is me setting up the themes of our movie
So I'm one I want to nail this. I don't want to throw this away. No, okay in a way
That's funny. Think got it. Okay
Enjoying your new permafrost, Olaf? I'm just living the dream, Anna. Oh how I wish this could last forever
And yet change mocks us with her beauty what's that forgive me maturity is making me poetic
Tell me you're older and thus all-knowing do you ever worry about the notion that
Nothing is permanent
No. Really?
Can't wait until I'm ancient like you so I don't have to worry about important things
Yeah, I'm tired too and Sven promised to read me a bedtime story.
Didn't you Sven?
and Sven promised to read me a bedtime story
you
know
I said come here, I said come here!
you do the best voices
Like when you pretend to be Kristoff and you're like hey
I just need to go talk to some rocks about my childhood and stuff. Oh
Yeah, we're calling this controlling what you can when things feel out of control. Oh
Yeah, we're calling this controlling what you can when things feel out of control
What he's sitting with a group of kids who they're you know, they're all those crystals that fall. Yes
They are decorating him with the crystals and so he looks ridiculous. Oh, yeah, she's got it's all those crystals
So he's talking as they're yet creative
So Kristoff said, you know
how you doing there Olaf and he's
very he's it's just showing the generosity of Olaf and he's looking after the kids and he's giving some really good advice on how you
Help kids get through difficult situations
okay, first we do that and then and then
so this is more like it's
It's he's kind of being like
pensive
And then this is a separate this is separate after that and that's later when everyone's like we're going I'm going I'm coming
I'm coming. I'll bring the snack. So that makes just fun to get I'm coming. Me too. I'll Drive I'll bring
Hey
Did you know did you know men are six times more likely to be struck by lightning?
Does that include snowmen only time will tell?
Only time and weather conditions will doubt
Did you know gorillas burp when they're happy go to zoo? Test it out. Well
Well, you're the grown ups, you know, can I try something a little?
Different better no not better just different
Well, well, that was unanimous then I'm still gonna look it up when I get home
Okay, so now Elsa stands on the shoreline of the dark sea and we see we start with crash this lightning and we go
Back and we see this figure who's Elsa looking out over the sea and these roaring turbulent waves
She gives a little look just gonna do a little like hmm. I got this sort of Nod
Hard cut to Elsa and she's standing there. Now she's drenched. She's right back where she started
And she takes off again. She's running running running
And we see the waves she runs past camera and leaps over the first set of waves as they crash down
As she forms this little ice ramp that she slides down and she runs again on the waves this time
she's getting close to making it but a huge wave is forming and she shoots with her ice forming this giant like
iceberg type thing that she was going to run up but it doesn't work and it comes crashing down onto her and she
Plunges down into the into the ocean and the camera goes now underwater as we see the roller
goes by and in between here
She'll start swimming and it's really really dark and the lightning will flash and that'll light up Elsa and then at the very end
As she's swimming we see a lightning flash which reveals but not course for them
This is gonna be a cinch two sisters one mind, okay, here we go you got this Elsa
Anytime just do something with your body
I know we did this together and we'll continue to do this together Anna and you to ask you a question
Do you want to build a snowman